what up Gooden think story here with
another genv trailer breakdown this time
for episode 6 is Soldier Boy really back
what fate awaits Kate I've left a link
to the trailer in the description below
for those of you who want to give it a
look and come on back keep in mind I've
not seen the episode so everything here
is sleuthing and huge shout out to
today's sponsor vurger let's get into it
vurger put our meat Burger in your mouth
hole okay our monster manipulator this
does not appear to be a good episode for
her as she faces the repercussions of
wiping the memories of her friends
without their consent I won't cuz I'm
all about consent Liar Liar last episode
we saw how she was working with Dean
Shetty to cover up the woods a secret
vot funded project that's working on a
virus against soups in my episode 5
video I theorized that Kate and the dean
might have a motherdaughter type
relationship something that Dean
leverages to get Kate to do her bidding
if you want to know all the evidence
that suggests that give that video a
look Dean chett may also be a soup in
Disguise and I think if she is her power
likely has something to do with the mind
she does have a gulkan degree in her
office but if you zoom in you can see
it's just a certificate of recognition
for her work as a professor so it
doesn't necessarily mean she attended
gulan and if she did attend gulan I
think everyone would know she had a
power Kate has this tear coming down her
face and is sweating we'll later see her
with these insane bloodshot eyes
something that normally happens when she
uses her power too much remember that
Kate is one of the only soups that is on
medication for her power could this
medication be used to suppress the full
extent of her powers did Dean Shetty
give her this medication from this shot
here it looks like Kate has passed out
I'm curious if she gave everyone their
Memories Back similar to what she did to
Andre and I also thought it was pretty
hilarious that the first memory she gave
back to him was him getting completely
stomped by Sam so she wakes up very
frightened and makes me think that she
experiences some sort ofad bad dream or
memory while unconscious we get this
shot and the vibe I get is that it could
be some sort of childhood bedroom with
the queen May posters in the background
is this her memory or someone else's as
she wakes up from this dream she reaches
for Marie but before she touches her
she's teleported as far as we know no
one including Kate has this ability I
don't think it was Kate who did this
rather someone else Andre Marie and
Jordan seemed shocked when this happened
so my best guess is that it's dusty who
we see here in the background we don't
know what his power is yet here we see
Marie in the frat house saying we do
this and there's no going back it looks
like she's talking to Andre and Jordan
I'm wondering if she's talking about
doing something to Kate or getting their
memories back because if they do get
their Memories Back they jeopardize
their lives by uncovering the truth
about the woods take a look at this
mysterious door we've seen this in other
trailers for the season it looks like it
could be a portal to a memory if it is
indeed Marie who opens this store with
which we see here with blood splattered
across it could it be a memory of the
day she killed her parents we get this
shot which looks to be Marie's boot
stepping into a blood-filled room with a
body laying on the ground to the left
the door from episode 1 also has the
same circular knob and her mother had to
break it down in order to get in Dusty
Jordan Marie and Andre find themselves
outside in the woods they're wearing
these same clothes from the frat house
and judging by this brick doorway
disassembling it appears they may have
stepped through some sort of portal in
the redband trailer we get this shot
which appears to be Marie and Jordan
stepping through it and is it just me or
does this doorway look a lot like the
one behind Andre which was made when
Andre blasted Rufus through the wall
although this shot is only 14 frames
long it tells us a lot Emma has made it
to the Frat House judging by the girls
get it done poster and red wallpaper in
the back but the thing I found
interesting here is that it looks like
Marie and Jordan are completely Frozen
behind her again it's just 14 frames so
it's hard to tell I do think Emma gets
her memories back we'll later see her
make out with Sam in front of a polarity
crane game her puppet hand kind of
seductively touches the glass so maybe
these two get it on and look who it is
in front of Andre that's golden boy
wearing the white shirt we've seen in
some of the other trailers Andre here
wears the same sweater from the frat
house and he looks kind of shocked to
see his best friend is this a memory a
vision with all these people with mind
Powers going on I wouldn't be surprised
I want you to take a look at the
background here this wooden paneling
we're back at gulan and we'll later see
Andre Jordan and Marie run away could
they be running away from this Dr
cardosa looking pretty concerned
remember he asked if he could have Marie
as a test subject something Dean Shetty
denied as Murray has a mysterious
benefactor in my episode 5 video I
theorized that this benefactor could be
Victoria Newman who will see visit gulan
for some sort of speech a shot of Andre
and Jordan back in the forest are they
looking at that door or something else
the background here looks kind of gray
and dead as opposed to this shot perhaps
it's just a bad angle this is really
interesting Marie says here what if it
kills her as Andre says just do
something if Andre is telling Marie to
do something it could mean he wants her
to do something involving her blood
Powers knowing Sam later arrives and
gets into a fight with Andre here my
best guess is that Sam has come to kill
Kate and injures her remember that Sam
knows Kate is part of the woods so he
definitely want to get some payback heck
he has a payback poster in his room
here's Jordan listening in outside
Brink's former office we can see that by
matching up this photo and the brink
poster in the corner has gulan hired a
new head of the crime fighting
department and if so who Dean Shetty and
Dr cardosa enter a cell this is not Sam
cell which we last Saw pretty much
destroyed it looks like they're
inspecting someone or something on the
floor in the season trailer we can see
other prisoners having to endure all
sorts of tests we even get this
mutilated person who may be the result
of Dr cardo's virus Jordan has found his
way into the woods with all this
speculation that we may be dealing with
dreams or visions I'm not entirely
certain this is the real woods Jordan
here is still wearing his blue jacket
from the frat house and we'll get this
shot of soldier boy standing in front of
a forest something about this feels off
now he could be standing in front of a
real forest or this could be a forest
background like the wallpaper found in
the woods the wallpaper we've seen so
far has been pretty desaturated not as
vibrant as what we see here maybe it's a
flashback to when the woods were first
created thus the wallpaper would be
brighter gulan after all was founded in
1965 the chances of this being soldier
boy in present day are very slim as the
last time we saw him he was knocked out
and imprisoned by Grace mallerie here's
Andre Jordan Dusty and Marie watching
something in the woods maybe they're
watching some sort of old memory of
soldier boy something that will link him
to the woods and or gulkan that's pretty
much it for this week's trailer let me
know what you think will happen next and
be sure to like And subscribe I cover
every episode so you'll want to stick
around for that thanks for watching for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember holy
a lot is
happening